[Music]
i don't have anyone here that has
tattoos but i saw something interesting
in the news
there's now a new
quicker more effective way to get rid of
unwanted tattoos check this out it's
apparently a laser process known as r20
and it lifts much more ink from the skin
in a fraction of the time
and i just thought i'd bring it up here
for reason i was just curious if if dave
our cameraman happened to see this
oh yeah
you bet your ass i did conan
and uh you know what what do you think
this is new yeah well i'm gonna go to
that place that does it after work okay
great because you know dave we can cover
for you so if you want you can go right
now just get it taken care of oh really
do you wanna do it right now don't you
think you should do it yeah i'm so tired
of looking like a monster yeah bye
everybody go ahead
goodbye dave good luck
so what can i do for you get this thing
off me
i feel like a free
[Applause]
oh man
what a relief thanks conan
wow that's great maybe now my wife will
come back all right
shut up dave
my kids used to cry when i was shirtless
all right all right all right
we understand the joke's the name